[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'un d'eux conviction que c'est lui tu
n'as rien approfondie ce sont les mots
du philosophe emile cioran approfondir
ces s'éloigner au moment de ses idées de
leurs maîtres une question le philosophe
français gaston bachelard dit que fa
surréel su qu'on croit savoir opus que
ce qu'on devrait savoir aujourd'hui je
vais vous proposer un moyen pour
surmonter cet obstacle
je commence avec un exemple sur le port
d'armes pour vous montrer comment nos
opinions peuvent le conduire un
observations ans précise et partielle de
la réalité
le port d'armes est un sujet assez
controversé dans plusieurs pays ue
brésil
il est interdit depuis 2003 et ses
sujets et discuté assez souvent par
toute la population est donc il ya
quelques semaines j'étais en train de de
regarder le débat sur l'internet et jeu
et j'ai trouvé en hand participants de
ce débat qu'il a à noter que après 2003
l'année de l'interdiction le nombre de
victimes d'armes à feu a augmenté alors
la loi sur les armements n'a pas été
efficace pour combattre la violence et
pour cette raison il était favorable à
l'armement de la population bon j'ai
décidé de chercher deux chiffres de
données officielles pour vérifier si
cette information était vrai ou non
et voilà ce que j'ai trouvé on constate
que malheureusement c'est vrai malgré
une diminution de nombre de décès par
armes à feu
juste après l'interdiction en 2003
aujourd'hui il a plus de victimes
donc je pensé ok donc peut-être on peut
vraiment dire que la loi sur le
désarmement n'a pas été une bonne idée
mais assez vite j'ai pu constater que
cette personne a fait une observation
partielle de la réalité parce que si on
regarde quelques années en arrière
depuis 1981
voilà ce que je peux retrouver observé
que la loi sur le désarmement un fait en
fait contribué au ralentissement de la
croissance du nombre de victimes
c'était en résultat plutôt positif
donc est ce qu'on peut vraiment dire je
suis favorable à la renommée de la
population tout simplement en regardant
la moitié de données voire moi non c'est
assez impartial à partiel mais bien sûr
que le débat ne s'arrête pas ici on peut
dire par exemple
ok mais si quelqu'un utilise un couteau
pour tuer quelqu'un parce que l'appât
d'aceh à deux armes à feu alors la
victime ne sera pas prise en compte dans
ces statistiques ici mais il s'agit
toujours d'un homicide
non mais quelle est la différence on
peut aussi supposer que le citoyen étant
des armées il devient plus difficile
d'agir en légitime défense
de sorte que peut-être
c'est l'avis du tribunal qui est épargné
et c'est là ne signifie pas que la
violence la criminalité ont diminué
d'autant plus que les armes utilisées
dans ces crimes là sont toujours illégal
via le continuation à circuler malgré la
prohibition l'interdiction mais bon il
faut aussi approfondir ce ses arguments
là sur ces questionnements
tout à fait mais ce qu'il faut retenir
de cet exemple ce qu'il est vraiment
difficile de connaître tous les facteurs
qui sont impliqués dans un sujet ne
parlons même pas sur la difficulté de
comprendre l'impact de chacun de ces
facteurs sur le résultat global
d'après vous combien de variables sommes
nous capables d'évaluer simultanément
pour prendre des décisions de 5,10
l'impasse et 4 selon l'article
combien de variables les humains
peuvent-ils traiter écrit par des
scientifiques australiens de
l'université de queensland et de
l'université griffith nous sommes
capables d'évaluer
maximum quatre variables simultanément
tout prendre des décisions pour
raisonner et dans ce contexte là je vous
pose une question combien de facteurs
faut-il prendre en compte pour évaluer
des sujets tels que la privatisation des
entreprises
les crises humanitaires économiques
politiques l'avortement l'euthanasie
le port d'armes et tous ces sujets
auxquels nous sommes confrontés au
quotidien
bon le problème ne pas l'opinion le
problème se forger une opinion et de la
diffuser sans avoir conscience de tous
ces facteurs qui sont impliqués cette
démarche dangereuse dans son oeuvre
psychologie technologie des idées
idiologie le psychologue américain barry
shott de fond que les idées peuvent
avoir des effets profonds même
lorsqu'elles sont fausses même
lorsqu'elles ne sont plus des idéologies
il propose une comparaison entre les
technologies et les idées sur la
technologie est mauvaise on a utilisé
plus elle disparaît mais c'est une idée
fausse les gens créent de manière de
vivre et d'institutions qui sont
cohérentes avec ses idées de sorte à les
rendre réel il y en histoire je veux
vous racontez moi non il s'agit d'une
histoire d'un vendeur de hot dogs
il va sur le bord de la route il n'avait
pas de radio ou de télévision
une lisa aucun journal mais il faisait
le meilleur homme de la région
il avait installé sur la route des
affiches pour faire connaître son
produit il le ventes augmentaient et le
plus en plus il achetait le meilleur
temps le meilleur saucisses il a même
acheté un poil inclut un peu plus grand
pour servir le nombre croissant de
clients et un jour il a décidé d'appeler
son fils pour l'aider en arrivant le
fise a remarqué que son père vit à comme
d'habitude ils vendent à dire d'orgue de
pensée de l'argent avec des affiches
donc il lui a dit papa
n'as tu pas écouter la radio ne tue pas
les journaux une grande dépression
s'annonce le scénario international et
bouleverser la situation domestique et
pire encore il faut économiser de
l'argent
craignant la crise le père cherchait un
fournisseur de pain un peu moins cher
la commencé à gîter des saucisses un peu
moins cher cela n'était pas suffisant
donc il a décidé de ne plus dépenser de
l'argent avec des affiches jeu pendant
quelques mois et avec sa mesure en place
finalement les ventes ont commencé à
diminuer a diminué et on diminue à 10
niveaux insupportables
le commerce de drogue contre x générer
des ressources assez physique
le père triste dit à son fils mon fils
tu avais raison
nous sommes vraiment en pleine période
de grande dépression de croyances
peuvent être auto réalisatrice
réfléchissez bien à propos de ce en quoi
vous croyez d'autant plus que nous
pouvons être de victimes d'idées et
d'arguments fallacieux car ils sont
souvent présentés de manière bien
structuré apparemment logique assez
convaincante et dans ce contexte je me
permets de mentionner encore une fois le
penser de gaston bachelard il dit qu'une
autre esprit à irrésistible de tendance
à considérer comme plus clair l'idée qui
lui sert le plus souvent efface cette
situation nous ne laissons convaincre
plus facilement par de sophismes par des
arguments qu'on a envie d'entendre
donc après avoir forgé une opinion
nous cherchons à la conforter et pour la
soutenir parfois nous utilisons le même
argument fallacieux qui nous enfants
vaincu nous avons tous déjà procédé de
cette manière mais la bonne nouvelle
c'est que ce défaut de raisonnement est
un fait naturel parce que la capacité à
raisonner et quelque chose qui demande
du temps pour être améliorés ou vérifier
cela il faut tout simplement que vous
réfléchissez à combien de personnes
sages à l'âge de 25 ans
connaissez
à trop juste pause selon george lakoff
professeur de linguistique cognitive à
l'université de californie
cessons de penser inconscient et
automatique qui tendent à former notre
positionnement politique ici parle du
positionnement politique
le jean se dire tu sais la pu
s'appliquer à tous les domaines de notre
vie
selon lui depuis que nous sommes des
enfants
nous avons la tendance associée des
expériences les unes avec les autres
lorsqu'ils se produisent simultanément
de façon récurrente par conséquent nos
expériences de bien-être et de mal être
sont souvent reliés à d'autres
expériences
je vous donne un exemple assez simple si
je ressemble de la peur dans l'obscurité
et je me sens soulagé quand il devient
clair
alors je vais percevoir l'obscurité
comme quelque chose de mauvais la
lumière comme quelque chose de bien
simple on est d'accord mais nous faisons
aussi ces genres des corrélations avec
des enjeux beaucoup plus profonds tels
que la moralité et l'immoralité et tout
au long de notre vie au sens d'une
culture d'une famille nous associons
certaine expérience au concept de
moralité et d'autres expériences ou
concept de l'immoralité et celles à ces
produits inconsciemment et nous mène à
défendre de façon automatique le point
de vue qu'il ne nuise pas à notre
conception de moralité
réfléchissez quelle est la réaction la
plus naturelle d'une personne quand elle
sent que sa conception de moralité mais
à l'épreuve
est ce qu'elle va dire un kill belle
opportunité de réfléchir vous mettre une
question de croyance super su convaincre
la plupart de temps à cette réaction là
que je vois mais pourquoi bien tout
simplement parce que c'est qu'une
personne juge être moralement correct et
construit au fil des années à travers
ces expériences
bien sûr
à travers l'opinion de ceux qui
l'entourent de ceux à qui elle fait
confiance
lalor une opinion contraire à la nôtre
nous est présenté nous sommes mises au
défi très souvent d'accepter que ce qui
a été si solidement construite en ou
peut-être faux mais qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour pour
nous autres vaslui qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire pour ne pas être aussi étonné que
ça dans ce genre de situation à l'école
primaire
grâce à mon ancienneté mon enseignante
d'histoire je peux connaître un moyen
très efficace que peut nous aider dans
ce genre de situation je veux partager
cette histoire avec vous elle a signé à
chacun d'entre nous la tâche de
représenter un président de la dictature
militaire au brésil
il fallait défendre son gouvernement et
ses actes et en revenant rôle d'étudiant
il fallait mettre en question les actes
des autres présidents le but de cette
activité était de faire connaître plus
profondément cette période de notre
histoire et j'ai été mise au défi de me
faire l'avocat du diable parce que quand
c'est ici où va le président qui m'a été
assignée à était le responsable de
l'institutionnalisation de la dictature
que tu as jusqu alors en régime
militaire du fuse ça commençait bien
son gouvernement se caractérisait par de
fortes pressions aux mouvements
d'opposition et grâce à l'acte
institutionnels numéro 5
une commerçante les libertés
démocratiques et les droits
constitutionnels des citoyens peuvent
être suspendus permettant à la police de
mener des enquêtes des poursuites et
même des arrestations sans avoir besoin
d'une ordre judiciaire et le résultat
bien sûr que cela conduit à du grain à
des violations des droits humains tels
que la torture et voilà maintenant que
j'étais chargé de défendre et je la fais
je pestais 10 mn à chercher des
arguments pour réfuter les accusations
il n'avait pas trop donc j'ai tenté de
trouver assez des points positifs dans
le but de détourner un peu l'attention
de ses petit scandale humanitaire
et à ma grande surprise je trouvais
plusieurs arguments
selon les témoignages de plusieurs
personnes qui ont vécu à cette époque
l'éducation est améliorée il ya eu plein
de plus grand développement industriel
de l'histoire du pays et la criminalité
a chuté il ya ceux qui disent qu'il se
sentait plus en sécurité
à cette époque là qu'aujourd'hui est bon
je montrais ses aspects du régime
militaire du gouvernement de constituer
ou 20 en tentant de de convaincre la
personne de leurs bénéfices et
condamnant l'impartialité avec laquelle
ce régime étaient jugés à la fin j'ai
une bonne note j'ai réussi l'exercice
mais j'ai vu que ça soit clair qu'en
régime extrémiste n'est certainement pas
moralement défendable
on est d'accord donc dans cette
situation ici jeu n'a pas changé mon
opinion mais moi j'ai pu la rendre mieux
informés grâce à toutes ces histoires
qui ne m'avait jamais été racontée mais
cela fait déjà huit ans que j'essaye de
répéter cette exercice
à chaque fois que je me rends compte je
suis en train de forger une nouvelle
opinion mais je vous invite à faire le
même essayé de défendre un point de vue
différent du vôtre voire opposées
surtout si vous n'avez pas l'habitude de
remettre en question les principes
fondamentaux de votre croyance vous
allez constater
de cette manière vous opinion ne
poseront plus un obstacle majeur à la
connaissance à la vérité il faut être
conscient que nous ne sommes pas des
sûrement capable de traiter 10 variable
de la foi qui nous opinion pomme nous
éloigner de la vérité de moi même si
l'opinion a souvent tort les moyens pour
surmonter cet obstacle sont ici sont à
notre disposition
socrates a déjà dit l'a longtemps
connais toi toi même
nous ne pouvons nous corriger que si
nous interrogeons notre savoir
trop souvent on entend sans écouter on
parle sans rien dire dans ce besoin
d'imposer nos idées nos opinions dans
cette peur d'avoir tort d'être contrarié
comme si le fait d'avoir quelque chose à
dire était plus important que notre
engagement la vérité en tant que membres
d'une école d'ingénieur nous sommes déjà
très habitués à la rigueur scientifique
pourquoi ne pas l'appliquer dans les
autres domaines de notre vie
il faut nous poser de bonnes questions
avant de chercher de réponse alors les
sur nos opinions clarifier plutôt
qu'obscure si les sons les édifier
plutôt qu'il détruira et surtout
laissons les nous rendre plus prudent
car c'est ainsi qu'ils nous allons
évoluer vers la sagesse la justice la
vérité de la tolérance merci
[Applaudissements]